pendant des années les québécois ont
voyagé partout sur la planète le mexique
la france l'inde le monde n'avait plus
de frontières mais avec la coved 19
quitte encore pas très loin dans le
rétroviseur il est recommandé de rester
au pays pour nos vacances est toujours
l'option de la gaspésie plus pas certain
que les gaspésiens ont envie de nous
revoir en aussi grand nombre et déjà
qu'ils s'approprient carrément le
territoire public qui font leurs besoins
dans le sens donc plusieurs pourraient
se tourner vers l'ouest canadien mais si
on veut y aller en respectant
l'environnement
on prend l'auto l'avion ou le train
pour prendre une décision on va utiliser
un calculateur d'empreinte carbone celui
de carbone boréal
c'est une chaire de recherche qui
offrent de compenser les émissions de
vos transports avec la plantation
d'arbres mais avant on va répondre à une
question qu'on explorer quelques mois
dans un autre reportage c'est quoi
l'empreinte carbone l'empreinte carbone
ça va représenter toutes les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ils vont avoir
lieu soit dans pour la production de ce
qu'on consomme soit que nous on va
émettre directement par exemple avec
notre transport premier scénario
un voyage de coop si nos deux voyageurs
qu'on visait les quelque quatre mille
six cents kilomètres qui relie montréal
et vancouver avec un petit des us ils
devront implanter huit arbres pour
compenser leur trajet s'ils prennent
l'avion en classe économique
ils devront implanter 9 pourquoi je
parle de classe économique
si par exemple notre coupe décidé de
faire le même trajet en classe affaires
comme il occupe plus de place dans
l'avion on leur attribuera une plus
grande part des gaz à effet de serre il
devrait donc en replanter 33 c'est
presque quatre fois plus qu'en classe
économique
donc pour nos amoureux l'automobile
serait la meilleure option par contre
attention s'il décide de prendre une
camionnette pour traîner par exemple une
roulotte et bien éventuellement l'avion
en classe économique pourrait devenir
une option plus écoresponsable donc
deuxième scénario maintenant une famille
de quatre qui prendrait la route dans sa
minifourgonnette elle devrait planter
novembre pour un trajet routier
comparativement à 17 pour l'avion en
classe économique et 65 en classe
affaire donc pour notre famille
l'automobile demeure beaucoup plus
écologique que l'avion grâce aux
avantages du covoiturage puis en plus
vos enfants ils vont adorer le nom de
l'ontario maintenant le train
logiquement on penserait que le train
c'est la façon la plus écologique de
traverser le pays
c'est d'ailleurs ce que prévoit la
majorité des calculateurs d'empreinte
carbone mais non
selon une nouvelle étude qui a été faite
à l'université d'ottawa le train au
canada est beaucoup plus polluant qu'on
peut le penser
en avril une caméra pourquoi les trains
canadiens sont-ils plus poliment 19h et
des manipulations et produits geste
garde fermée nivelles et file au nigeria
avant de vous laisser une petite
précision les chiffres qu'on vient de
vous donner c'est seulement pour l'aller
donc il faut les multiplier par 2 pour
la libido
finalement on va peut-être y retourner
en gaspésie gens viennent commun s'ils
viennent camper une fois la partie
c'est qu'on voit beaucoup de bouteilles
de bière se faisait par les filles il y
avait lors que c'était sur facebook que
tout le monde avait le droit de cave est
partout